hello everyone let me introduce myself
as Sam a multi-platform cloud architect
and trainer and I'm so glad and I'm
equally excited to talk and walk you
through the session about what aw exists
and talk to you about some services and
offerings and about how companies get
benefitted by migrating their
applications and infra into AWS so
what's a double use let's talk about
that now before that let's talk about
how life was without any cloud provider
and in this case how life was without a
double years so let's walk back and
picture how things were back in 2000
which is not so long ago but a lot of
changes a lot of changes for better had
happened since that time now back in
2000 at a quest for a new server is not
an happy thing at all because a lot of
money lot of validations lot of planning
are involved in getting a server online
or up and running and even after we
finally got the server it's not all said
and done a lot of optimization that
needs to be done on that server to make
it worth it and get a good return on
investment from that server and even
after we have optimized for a good
return on investment the work is still
not done there will often be a frequent
increase and decrease in the capacity
and you know even news about our website
getting popular and getting more hits
it's still and bittersweet experience
because now I need to add more servers
to the environment which means that it's
going to cost me even more but thanks to
the present-day cloud technology if the
same situation were to happen today my
new server it's almost ready and it's
ready instantaneously and with the Swift
tools and technologies that Amazon is
providing in providing my server
instantaneously and adding any type of
workload on top of it and making my
storage and server secure you know
creating a durable storage where data
that I store in the cloud never gets
lost with all that features Amazon has
are back so let's talk about what is AWS
there are a lot of definitions for it
but I'm going to put together a simple
and a precise definition as much as
possible now let me iron that out cloud
still runs on and hardware right and
there are certain features in that
infrastructure in that cloud
infrastructure that makes cloud cloud or
that makes AWS a cloud provider now we
get all the services all the
technologies all the features and all
the benefits that we get in our local
data center like you know security and
compute capacity and databases and in
fact you know we get even more cool
features like content caching in various
global locations around the planet but
again out of all the features the best
part is that I get or we get everything
on a pay as we go model the less I use
the less I pay and the more I use the
less I pay per unit very attractive
isn't it right and that's not all the
applications that we provision in AWS
are very reliable because they run on an
reliable infrastructure and it's very
scalable because it runs on an on-demand
infrastructure and it's very flexible
because of the designs and because of
the design options available for me in
the cloud let's talk about how all this
happened
AWS was launched in 2002 after the
Amazon we know as the online retail
store wanted to sell their remaining or
unused infrastructure as a service or as
an offering for customers to buy and use
it from them you know sell
infrastructure as a service the idea
sort of clicked and AWS launched their
first product first product in 2006
that's like four years after the idea
launched and in 2012 they held a
big-sized customer even together inputs
and concerns from customers and they
were very dedicated in making those
requests happen and that habit is still
being followed it's still being followed
as reinvent by AWS
and at 2015 Amazon announced its revenue
to be 4.6 billion and in 2015 through
2016
aw launched products and services that
help migrate customer services into AWS
well there were products even before but
this is when a lot of focus was given on
developing migrating services and in the
same year that's in 2016
Amazon's revenue was 10 billion and not
but not the least as we speak
Amazon has more than hundred products
and services available for customers and
get benefitted from alright let's talk
about the services that are available in
Amazon let's start with this product
called s3 now s3 is a great tool for
internet backup and it's it's the
cheapest storage option in the object
storage category and not only that the
data that we put in s3 is retrievable
from the internet s3 is really cool and
we have other products like a migration
and data collection and data transfer
products and here we can not only
collect data seamlessly but also in a
real-time way monitor the data or
analyze the data that's being received
that their cool products like AWS data
transfers available that helps achieve
that and then we have products like ec2
Elastic Compute cloud that's an
resizable computer where we can anytime
anytime alter the size of the computer
based on the need or based on the
forecast then we have simple
notification services systems and tools
available in Amazon to update us with
notifications through email or through
SMS now anything anything can be sent
through email or through SMS if we use
that service it could be alarms or it
could be service notifications if you
want stuff like that and then we have
some security tools like KMS key
management system which uses aes 256-bit
encryption to enter our data at rest
then we have lambda as service for which
we pay only for the time in seconds
seconds it takes to execute our code and
we're not paying for the infrastructure
here it's just the seconds the
is gonna take to execute the quarter for
the short program we'll be paying in a
milliseconds if it's a bit bigger
program will be probably paying in 60
seconds or 120 seconds but that's not
cheap lot simple and lots cost effective
as against paying for service on an
hourly basis which a lot of other
services are well that's cheap but using
lambda is a lot cheaper than that and
then we have services like route 53 a
DNS service in the cloud and now I do
not have to maintain and DNS account
somewhere else and my cloud environment
with AWS I can get both in the same
place all right let me talk to you about
how AWS makes life easier or how
companies got benefitted by using AWS as
their IT provider for their applications
or for the infrastructure now Unilever
is a company and they had a problem
right and they had a problem and they
picked AWS
as a solution to their problem right now
this company was sort of spread across
190 countries and they were relying on a
lot of digital marketing for promoting
their products and their existing
environment their legacy local
environment proved not to support their
changing IT demands and they could not
standardize their old environment
now they chose to move part of their
applications to AWS because they were
not getting what they wanted in their
local environment and since then you
know rollouts were easy provision in
your applications became easy and even
provisioning infrastructure became easy
and they were able to do all that in
push button scaling and needless to talk
about backups that are safe and backups
that can be securely accessed from the
cloud as needed now that company is
growing along with AWS
because of their Swift speed in rolling
out deployments and being able to access
secure backups from various places and
generate reports and in fact useful
reports out of it that helps their
business now on the same lines let me
also talk to you about Kellogg's and how
they got benefitted by using Amazon now
Kellogg's had a different problem it's
one of its kind now their business model
is very dependent on an infra that will
help to analyze data really fast right
because they were running promotions
based on the analysed data that they get
so they're being able to respond to the
analyzed data as soon as possible worse
critical or vital in their environment
and luckily SAP running on Hana
environment is what they needed and you
know they picked that service in the
cloud and that's sort of solved the
problem now the company does not have to
deal with maintaining their legacy infra
and maintaining their heavy compute
capacity and maintaining their database
locally all that is now moved to the
cloud or they are using cloud as their
IT service provider and and now they
have a greater and powerful IT
environment and that very much
complements their business
I believe you enjoyed watching this
video stay tuned I'll meet you in
another video thank you hi there if you
like this video subscribe to the simple
learn YouTube channel and click here to
watch similar videos turner up and get
certified click here